et maintenant j'accueille Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
salut Gaspard bonjour bonjour C'est
salut salut
je suis vraiment très content de
reprendre je tenais à le dire parce que
ça se voit pas toujours sur mon visage
et c'est un vrai bonheur de donner du
plaisir aux gens
en tout cas public vraiment merci du
fond du cœur pour vos like vos tweets et
enfin
tous vos pouces que vous mettez sous la
vidéo sur le site Canal pour dire que la
vidéo est au dessus c'est c'est vraiment
un geste pratique parce que sinon on la
trouverait pas et
alors moi cet été bon je suis assez féru
de culture j'aime pas trop les endroits
chauds donc je suis allé à Dubaï
c'est beau c'est beau Dubaï c'est c'est
comme la défense mais au milieu du Sahel
quoi c'est si tu détestes la nature
c'est vraiment un chouette endroit pour
lâcher prise
[Applaudissements]
alors bon
la main d'oeuvre bon c'est que des
Pakistanais des Indiens des sri-lankaise
ça fait ça fait bizarre au début c'est
parce que de visu physiquement on dirait
un peu des Roms alors et en fait il te
demande juste alors est-ce que la viande
est bien cuite encore un mojito et ah on
l'a retrouvé votre portefeuille face ça
fait bizarre au début
et je te parle pas des femmes parce que
là-bas les femmes c'est c'est du pudeur
tout dans les yeux
c'est bon c'est normal tout le reste est
couvert quoi je veux dire tu as
l'impression qu'elle passe leur temps à
chercher un bloc opératoire
bon au niveau culture je suis pas rentré
bredouille enfin j'ai quand même visité
un musée par là-bas ils appellent ça un
centre commercial c'est j'ai déniché un
très très chouette bibelot que je
voulais donc c'est un mug enfin
osez le féminisme
d'ailleurs j'ai bu une vodka dedans je
me suis trouvé super subversif quoi
bon enfin bref sinon qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé récemment alors le devoir de
vacances des ministres a été de pondre
un rapport sur ce que sera la France en
2025 alors ils sont tous optimiste c'est
le rapport qui aurait pu s'appeler ça
ira mieux quand on sera plus là
c'est genre ces trucs après nous le
paradis quoi
en gros en 2025 tout sera réglé c'est
quand même bizarre quoi des gens de
gauche qui sont convaincus que tout sera
génial quand le FN sera au pouvoir
ça se raconte je veux dire FN en 2025
c'est Philippot ministre de la Justice
Serge Ayoub ministre de la Culture
alors au pif alors dans les prospectives
il y a Montebourg qui prévoit qu'en 2025
il y aura la France qui fera partie du
concert des grandes nations
industrielles il annonce qu'on va
inventer un moyen de transport qui
consomme 2 litres au sang
ça existe déjà ça s'appelle un cheval
[Musique]
et surtout en 2025 Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem sera majeur
un peu de patience pour les mecs
sinon quoi d'autre alors oui il y a un
mouvement alors j'ai cité oser le
féminisme c'est un peu en vrac à qui
milite pour l'entrée des femmes au
Panthéon moi je suis pour après la
question pourquoi seulement des femmes
mortes
alors elles ont toutes en commun un truc
elle défendent la cause des femmes
si on fait entrer au Panthéon des femmes
juste parce qu'elle défendent les femmes
alors de la même manière pour les hommes
faudra prévoir une place pour Bigard et
dska
c'est dans les l'été c'est aussi l'amour
parce que c'est important quoi la love
story de l'été Val staubira et une
révélation la prison crée des
délinquants c'est vrai en général les
mecs qui arrivent en prison c'est parce
qu'ils ont été acquittés
on veut réduire la peine de prison
mettre des peines probatoire on a raison
on a raison faut avouer faute à moitié
pardonner il faut des prisons plus
spacieuses et confortables moi je vois
depuis que le club Meder ces villages
j'ai plus de plaisir à y aller c'est un
truc je sais pas
non faut sortir d'une certaine démagogie
si je peux me permettre
parce que si un mec est en prison c'est
que quelque part il y a une injustice
moi je connais des victimes
qu'est-ce qu'une personne âgée fou avec
100 euros en liquide dans son sac à main
statistiquement 100% des victimes ont
croisé un agresseur
dire la provoque un moment ça suffit
quoi
et on l'oublie mais souvent le
délinquant est plus dans le besoin
financier que la victime
ça ouais que j'allais oublier un truc
que super important la commémoration
alors il y a une semaine c'était le 50e
anniversaire du discours i hate a dream
c'est quand même très émouvant
cet homme qui parce qu'il est noir est
obligé de raconter son rêve en dehors
d'un cabinet de psychiatre
la pauvreté ça pousse toujours à
l'impruder
la Syrie que ça bouge là-bas
c'est les attaques chimiques alors ils
ont envoyé des experts pour vérifier je
sais pas si Christine Boutin était dans
l'équipe est-ce qu'elle s'est faite
gazer tu vois
et elle connaît bien sûr
pas d'intervention internationale quoi
mais ça c'est notre rapport aux
personnes âgées quand on sera toujours
plus émus par un enfant musulman qui
suffoque une grand-mère catholique qui
tousse
et le problème c'est c'est le côté c'est
le mot chimique c'est le côté gazage ça
rappelle les heures sombres quoi c'est
les gens ils supportent pas quoi ça le
rappelle trop quand il se trouve coincé
aux heures de pointe sur le péril dans
un tunnel Bagnolet
en fait les armes chimiques c'est un peu
comme la fellation quoi comme sucer
n'est pas trompé flinguer n'est pas
exterminé
c'est un peu ça c'est pas
en tout cas là maréchal des logis chefs
Hollande il va y aller
Saint-Tropez qui tire la bourre avec
Rambo quoi
ça c'est
[Applaudissements]
ça s'explique c'est l'effet Mali quoi
depuis qu'il a cartonné là-bas
du mec qui vient tout juste de perdre
son pucelage quoi c'est le type il vient
de se taper la fille facile du village
et qui va raconter à tous ses potes
c'est le loup blanc dans tous les bars à
de Saigon
il faut expliquer un peu la Syrie c'est
un pays c'est pas un paysage quoi c'est
chef du village c'est pas un chaman qui
lit dans les entrailles de patates
douces
parce que Bachar il a une certaine
classe
tu lui mets à haute forme un parapluie
ça Englishman à Damas
après faut être juste il faut être juste
est-ce que la France peut intervenir
toute seule oui
on a envoyé une frégate de zodiaque
enfin c'est bon on parle aussi de deux
ULM peut-être 3 si un Artus Bertrand
répond oui tu vois
[Applaudissements]
on va finir par une bonne nouvelle pas
plomber sur la guerre alors la location
adulte handicapé va aussi augmenter de
1,75% cette année je l'écoute pouce pour
pouvoir d'achat des fonctionnaires alors
avec la vie
[Applaudissements]
je suis content je suis content de te
voir c'est moi aussi si tu es là c'est
que tu as retrouvé du boulot
non mais c'est vrai mais il est là pour
pour une pièce de théâtre
c'est pas encore ça non mais il faut
être lucide le théâtre c'est quoi c'est
foyer Emmaüs du cinéma
la SPA des producteurs parfois ils
adoptent et puis froid deux trois films
4 puis après on voit l'acteur attaché
bordel l'autoroute des vacances comme ça
enfin dans le jargon ça s'appelle un
téléfilm sur TF1 quoi
enfin bref la semaine alors cette
semaine nous avons été à 11 septembre
c'est une date très très importante
l'anniversaire de Bachar el-Assad
et on comprend mieux certaines choses il
est vierge alors maintenant sachant que
sa femme est née le 11 août la seule
vraie question qui se pose c'est quoi
est-ce que ça peut durer entre un vierge
et une lion
cette combinaison peut fonctionner très
bien le lion peut offrir l'imagination
et l'excitation alors que la Vierge peut
offrir son esprit d'analyse son sens de
l'ordre
c'est et nous on veut briser ce couple
[Applaudissements]
mais
quand qu'on les laisse s'aimer
[Rires]
tout ça parce que Hollande il prend la
guerre en Syrie pour un jeu vidéo
d'arcade à trois niveaux tu sais le
niveau simple c'est le Mali tu sautes
sur les dromadaires du manioc
en Syrie tu rajoutes le paysage urbain
puis troisième niveau très difficile là
c'est Marseille tu attrapes inquiéter de
rue
je me disais à propos de Bachar qu'on
voulait punir détruire supprimer
vraiment à la shlag quoi
Bachar par rapport à la réforme Taubira
c'est quand même bizarre de vouloir
mettre en place des peines de probation
pour des délinquants reconnus coupables
en France et en même temps envisager la
peine de mort pour des suspects présumés
innocents à l'étranger
[Applaudissements]
le sport évidemment le je pensais
important de parler aussi un peu de
pelouse il y a il y a un malaise Benzema
dans l'équipe de France arrêtons de la
câbler et le mec il gagne 8,5 millions
d'euros par an au Real équipe de France
tu touches 15000 euros par match à ce
tarif il est déjà gentil de toucher la
balle
Benzema en équipe de France et c'est
Alain Ducasse qui vient faire une pige
au McDo quoi
alors après l'équipe de France n'est pas
toujours irréprochable dans ses demandes
dans ces complets
elle se plaint d'être mal aimé
c'est sûr que c'est pas en allant au
que tu te fais une idée complète de
l'amour quoi
le bon coin oui aux États-Unis des
couples revendent des enfants qu'ils ont
adopté et les revendre sur internet
alors jusque là pourquoi pas mais en
revanche les argumentaires de vente je
suis tombé sur une annonce je cite j'ai
honte de le dire mais le détestons
vraiment cet enfant
c'est quand même malheureux de vendre
ton gosse comme ça je veux dire si tu
vends une voiture tu dis pas vends
voiture pourrie qui n'a été qu'une
source d'emmerde
alors forcément je me suis retiré des
enchères j'ai pas j'ai pas éducation
payons Vincent a sorti sa charte sur la
laïcité ça ne va servir à rien il faut
que les gens puissent s'identifier
laïcité laïcité personne connaît la cité
des 4000 les Tarterêts mais laïcité
leur payant veut refendre les programmes
ça c'est la maraude des nouveaux
ministres des dès qu'ils arrivent quand
tu arrives à l'éducation nationale tu
refais les programmes c'est l'éducation
nationale c'est le seul endroit où les
mises à jour rendent le système moi
performant qu'avant safari un éléphant a
tué un vieillard avec sa trompe en
Seine-et-Marne c'est pas étonnant en ce
moment tu sais les éléphants ils
quittent les hauts plateaux de Picardie
pour aller rejoindre le bassin
francilien faut vraiment respecter
l'équilibre fragile de cette région
c'est un écosystème d'une beauté absolue
quoi spectacle extraordinaire bon
récemment je suis allé en baie de
Saint-Malo voir l'accouplement des
crocodiles
c'était sublime c'est quand tu vois le
crocodile affalé comme ça et que
l'Improviste un ours polaire qui passe
il y a une
[Applaudissements]
sport toujours
Kevin le fait jusque là ça ne dit rien à
personne c'est normal c'est un attaquant
du Red Star qui souffre d'une fracture
du nez alors c'est un petit jeune qui
monte juste envie de dire la coke c'est
avec une paille pas avec un marteau
cinéma
la rentrée d'Alain Delon qui a déclaré
que l'homosexualité était contre nature
dire ça au 21e siècle faire l'apologie
de l'hétérosexualité
pour Alain Delon l'homosexualité contre
nature il a fait Rocco et ses frères
non mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
encourager les l'hétérosexualité quand
on sait que statistiquement monsieur
scout il vous le dites jamais tous les
délinquants je dis bien tous les délins
sont les enfants d'un couple hétéro
en débat on vous l'a jamais fait cela
pas encore
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est c'est grave c'est grave
que fait Pierre Berger
économie alors la police vient de
démanteler le plus grand camp de Rome à
Lille en fait les flics ne sont plus en
concurrence avec la gendarmerie mais
avec des mécos ça devient les types ils
savent plus arrêter un coupable en
revanche ils savent parfaitement comment
on fait bouger une caravane ou une
armoire normande c'est
alors les Roms enfin il y a un endroit
très simple pour les reloger c'est
toujours un problème il pourrait faire
partie de l'expo permanente du Salon de
la caravane Porte de Versailles et ben
voilà et alors
mémoire à l'Allemagne va renvoyer devant
la justice les gardes du camp
d'Auschwitz
à l'époque les mecs ils avaient 21 ans
enfin faut se remettre dans le contexte
en 40 en Allemagne gardien de Caen
c'était un emploi d'avenir
amour de vieux ont été retrouvés ligotés
dans une maison voilà ce qui arrive
quand on joue des jeux SM et qu'à cause
d'Alzheimer on a oublié le mot de passe
pour dire stop
[Applaudissements]
alors bonne nouvelle de la semaine un
bijoutier touche un braqueur je tiens à
rassurer tout le monde le scooter marche
toujours alors ma belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
au fait quand même partie de France 2
c'est une chaîne dont je salue les choix
stratégiques non
c'était bien mais franchement un duo
entre David Bowie est placé vos ça a
quand même vachement moins de classe
qu'un live de Sofia Aram quoi
non parce que cette année France 2 en
termes de programmation c'est ça met une
claque à tout le monde
surtout à ces animateurs maison c'est
pas comme ça Sofia c'est plus une claque
c'est une lapidation que c'est moi je
savais pas quelqu'un produisait des
émissions
cela dit je trouve très courageux de
bosser pour le service public
être soumis à la loi de l'audimat tout
en ayant les salaires de la fonction
publique
alors
je ne vais pas parler que de la
télévision parce qu'on est aussi des
invités
la chance d'avoir Marie-Noëlle ce soir
sur plateau c'est je suis votre champion
là le président camarade
social-démocratique
en fait il s'en fout un peu de votre
demande j'ai eu l'impression enfin il a
mis mon debout pour faire le cake devant
les chaînes de montage mais enfin bon
ça avait relancé le pouvoir d'achat ça
serait quoi je veux dire et j'ai suivi
l'intervention du camarade Hollande
alors dimanche il a découvert que la
France souffrait d'un ras-le-bol fiscal
et incroyable vous savez c'est comme un
chirurgien qui opère son anesthésie il
va voir le patient lui dit ça a
dû faire mal
[Applaudissements]
alors non mais les gens les gens ils
l'alchent Hollande n'ont pouvoir d'achat
alors lui il est là il répond j'ai
entendu cette préoccupation
et je veux y apporter une réponse sur la
fiscalité ce qu'on va faire cette année
c'est qu'avec la décote du crédit
d'impôt dans l'hypothèse on augmente la
CSG de 2%. la va prendre 1,99 pour pas
compliquer et en tenant compte d'une
croissance de la dépense publique gelée
dans son point d'indice de façon à ce
qu'elle dépasse pas le plafond supérieur
du barème il sera rétrocédé à tous les
contribuables je dis bien à tous les
contribuables c'est-à-dire même ceux
dont le quotient familial représente un
delta de 12 si on prend pour référentiel
le temps de maturation d'une fine de
Claire numéro 6
il sera rétrocédé le quart de l'impôt
qui devait être perçu sur une moyenne
des cinq dernières années
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr je le dis dans une hypothèse
d'inflation à 1,456%
mensualisé c'est à dire pour simplifier
racine carrée de pi
alors l'autre ça veut dire quoi pour ma
retraite
pour la retraite c'est pareil
bon c'est simple
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
qui va être compensée par un compte
pénibilité indexé sur le tiers payant de
votre mutuelle calculée
au détail de la côte de porc
ou du radis selon les saisons car je
veux aussi tenir compte des difficultés
que connaissent nos exportateurs pour
l'évêque
enfin moi je l'entends parler je me dis
mais là en fait il vient de mettre de la
vaseline ou pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
non mais je pense que s'il y a pas de
contestation sociale violente en ce
moment c'est pas parce que les réformes
sont bonnes mais c'est parce que
personne les comprend
[Applaudissements]
ouais
bling bling is back ah oui la descend
c'est de retour en France qui sont
les Français qui sont les Français c'est
la crise et les gens se mobilisent pour
un bijoutier
moi ce qui m'impressionne chez les
braqueurs de bijoutier c'est leur
rapidité pour choisir les bijoux
ils savent tout de suite ce qu'ils
veulent fais-moi une fois je regarde un
braquage j'ai dit à ma copine vas-y
prends de la graine quoi franchement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après après on dit que le type c'est un
récidiviste
on le sait bien le goût des belles
choses ça se construit pas en une nuit
alors évidemment la famille du braqueur
dit que la confiance en la justice tu
m'étonnes quoi c'est normal après 14
récidives toujours en liberté
[Applaudissements]
non mais il y a beaucoup d'inépies sur
ce sujet beaucoup on dit que c'est un
truc réactionnaire 1,5 millions de
personnes qui like
c'est quand même vachement rare que des
réseaux d'extrême droite soutiennent un
mec qui s'appelle turc
ce qui est inquiétant c'est que 1,5
millions de like en une semaine ça va
donner des idées de buzz à certains quoi
il paraît que depuis le phénomène des
bijouteries dans le Sud-Ouest on l'a
déjà vu François Bayrou Rodez près des
bijouteries
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors il a acheté les voies des gens
pour se faire élire à Corbeil-Essonnes
il faut comprendre aussi à son âge il
tente le tout pour le tout se faire
élire mère de Corbeil et essayer de
faire racheter des rafales à sa police
municipale voilà
il y a un bras de marre on met un
porte-avion c'est bon c'est calé quoi
déplacement Cahuzac veut qu'on lui
rembourse ses frais de déplacement pour
les auditions de la commission des
finances et bah oui un billet de train
plein d'essence il est con aussi quoi il
aurait refusé de venir il aurait eu un
transport gratuit voiture sirène escorte
et tout type
plein air Perpignan
un peu de soleil il enlève son ex
compagne là-bas Nanterre et se dénonce
c'est un peu con
franchement il aurait commencé par la
fin il avait l'après-midi libre pour
faire de la planche à voile
[Applaudissements]
alors on va terminer par la bonne
nouvelle parce qu'il faut quand même
mettre de l'espoir et de la confiance
parce que sans ça il y a pas de
DSK retrouver un job la conseiller le
gouvernement serbe pour redresser la
situation économique locale alors ça a
pas dû être très difficile de convaincre
qu'on lui a dit venez ici c'est un grand
bordel
alors ta belle la vie
bonsoir
c'est c'est pas Hollande qui disait
qu'il comptait sur une défaite de Merkel
au législative oui
de visionnaire
quand il se retira de la politique
pourra toujours faire l'horoscope sur
RTL sur un truc oui Merkel a bien gagné
bon c'est un triomphe mais ça pas été le
fasse non plus quoi les bosses c'est
plus que c'était c'est pas pas de parade
sur les champs personne rue Lauriston je
me sentais bien seul au Lutetia
à propos de guerre hey patoche enfin
pardon monsieur meluche
ça n'a pas été trop dur de traverser les
checkpoint que tiennent les shebabs des
quartiers nord de Marseille pour
non parce que c'est fou en trois heures
TGV Paris Marseille était en zone libre
enfin ça doit faire quelque chose de
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas pour votre demande de tout à
l'heure en coulisse il y a pas de
problème je vais signer votre gilet par
balle c'est pas de
à Marseille Marseille
Vieux tous les excès Marseille vous le
savez c'est cette mosaïque de diversité
de différence de non similitudes
d'antithèses de contradiction de
disparité de disproportion de
dissemblances de dissimilitude de
distance de distinction des cars
d'hétérogénéité d'un compatibilité
d'inégalité de nuances de variétés et là
ça reste mon dictionnaire des synonymes
emploi
alors il paraît que l'inversion de la
courbe du chômage est en train de se
produire c'est grâce aux emplois jeunes
mais c'est une très bonne idée alors moi
je suis allé sur le site des emplois
jeunes il y a des témoignages
extraordinaires c'est aussi un travail
de journaliste c'est pas que de la
bouffonnerie il y a attention témoignage
de Cindy après plusieurs missions de
nettoyage la Mission Locale du propose
une formation MHL maintenant et hygiène
des locaux suivi d'une formation SST
Sauveur secouriste du travail c'est
vachement bien surtout qu'une fois que
tu as les deux diplômes tu peux
fusionner les formations MHL et SST pour
obtenir un diplôme MST
autre exemple parce qu'il y a plusieurs
emplois bien sûr elle a entendu alors
Jean si on va prendre un nom d'emprunt
après une semaine d'essai au sein de la
mairie Jean a fait l'unanimité et s'ils
sont contrat dans la foulée et là ainsi
déjà participé à plusieurs formations
l'une sur le fonctionnement des
collectivités locales et l'autre sur le
classement des emails
classement des emails ce métier d'avenir
considérable attention c'est que le
début on prévoit aussi des métiers comme
éboueur de corbeille Windows
redémarreur de PC
manutentionnaire de la touche caps lock
c'est
sur PC parce que sur Mac c'est une autre
formation
il y a pas que ça ce qui compte aussi
c'est des métiers d'avenir liés à la
sensibilisation aux éco-gestes
animations conseils des choses
extraordinaires des alors tout ça c'est
vrai ambassadeur des économies d'eau
à quoi
il y a aussi ambassadeur de la
prévention des déchets
tout vous ne représentation dans un
local poubelle et puis tu
sais pas enfin c'est pas moi alors
j'attends encore le grand chambellan du
plus moélectrostatique ou le ministre
délégué au trace calcaire enfin c'est
très
à Michel Sapin il devrait pas faire
ministre de l'Emploi mais chef de fil
des nouveaux poètes quoi c'est pas le
successeur de DSK mais de Salvador Dali
Rome Mania oui en ce moment les Roms tu
as l'impression que c'est les Spice
Girls
les Roms qui sont pourtant très utiles à
la France contrairement à tout c'est
insupportable c'est un supportable il
souligne les gaspillages de France
Télévisions bah oui pourquoi laisser
Frédéric Lopez emmener des acteurs à
l'autre bout de la terre avec des moyens
considérables alors qu'il suffit de
passer la porte de la chapelle pour
vivre une aventure humaine hors du
commun
[Applaudissements]
plutôt que de voir Zabou chez les Inuits
du détroit de Béring nous restons pas de
voir Jean Roucas chez les Roms de la
bretelle de Sarcelles
mais bon il faut que les rhums reste
lucide c'est engouement ses provisoire
c'est un effet de mode ça peut pas durer
c'est fragile Rome sachez une chose vous
n'allez pas vivre longtemps sur vos
acquis vos privilèges
après Valls a dérapé c'est sûr il a dit
les Roms on vocation à rester en
Roumanie en Bulgarie alors déjà leur
dire de partir c'est pas facile mais en
plus les humiliés en leur expliquant
qu'ils ne méritent pas mieux que le
Bangladesh européen psychologie
message d'espoir pour toutes les
familles qui ont un proche dans une
secte avec de la volonté on peut s'en
sortir merci à toi pour cette leçon de
courage Noël ma mère
communication Matignon a recruté une
conseillère en communication pour Madame
Hérault alors ça commence à porter ses
fruits il paraît qu'elle est très à
l'aise avec la méthode syllabique
amour alors un Yéménite est mort après
avoir bouffé 5 pilules de Viagra alors
qu'ils se préparer pour sa nuit de noces
on l'a retrouvé mort tout ce que l'on
croyait être une tente
et dans la même veine
un Colombien de 66 ans a été amputé de
la verge car il avait surdosé le Viagra
érection qui a duré 5 jours boom la
gangrène alors tout n'est pas perdu
puisque avec la peau abandonnée par
l'homme on pourra reconstituer l'organe
de la femme
parce que 5 jours enfin voilà quoi
beauté on a interdit les concours de
mini miss c'est peut-être mieux pour
l'ego de Mimie Mathy
musique Patrick Bruel siffler et hué par
35000 personnes lors de l'inauguration
d'un nouveau stade à Nice ce qui enlève
quelques préjugés sur les Niçois ils ont
peut-être la gâchette facile mais au
moins c'est des mélomanes
alors une bonne nouvelle de la semaine
peut-être on vient de trouver une tonne
3 de cocaïne dans un avion à Paris
malgré ce coup dur saluons le courage
des organisateurs d'avoir pu tout de
même maintenir la Fashion Week alors les
actualités très bien France polémique
valse Duflot alors il paraît que
Hollande a recadrer ses ministres ça a
dû être un truc
dantesque au moment où il l'a fait dans
la savane la vie s'est arrêtée le
crocodile a lâché sa proie des papillons
sont tombés en torche
heureusement que la porte du Conseil des
ministres était bien fermé parce que
sinon le mec il déplaçait un fuseau
horaire
alors on reprend chez Hollande son
manque d'autorité ça c'est de la
perspicacité pure ça se voit sur son
physique tu l'imagines chaque requis
avec sa bouille de hamster sous MDMA
en ce moment il va extrêmement mal quoi
enfin il a promis de revenir tous les
ans à Florence
avec son salaire il peut aller ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
mais je comprends que ce soit désolant
ce manque d'autorité enfin moi plus je
vois le manque d'autorité de Hollande en
France plus je me pose des questions sur
la force de caractère du peuple malien
Rome derrière toutes ces polémiques il y
a une question pourquoi est-ce qu'on
stigmatise les Roms mais la réponse est
simple parce que ça détend
bien
c'est le pied enfin c'est ça c'est le
principe du bouc émissaire qui s'écrit
dans la Bible moi j'ai pas les moyens de
m'acheter un bouc de le pousser dehors à
chaque fois que j'ai un péché enfin je
veux dire je il y a le rhum il est là
maintenant
laissez-moi au moins ces gens là parce
que je veux pas prendre l'émission en
otage je suis pas là pour ça mais bon
moi quand je suis arrivé ici je
détestais tout le monde vraiment et puis
l'émission bon j'ai découvert qu'il y a
des Juifs qui travaillent ici
c'est dur de le dire mais en fait il y a
des mecs sympas
alors je me dis bon va pour les Juifs ok
je fais avec j'accepte alors je dis bon
il y a quelques Arabes là je me dis tu
vois alors je fais des chroniques très
anti halal et tout j'ai discuté avec
certains mais c'est des gens enfin comme
nous quoi
alors qu'est-ce que je fais en plus le
pire tu vois il y a des Noirs à
l'émission là je me dis je vais pas me
faire avoir
tu te souviens quand je suis venu ici je
bon j'ai rapporté à tous un petit pot de
avec le truc de
et en fait c'est dur est-ce que c'est
vrai qu'ils ont pas que le rythme dans
la peau
ils ont une conversation quoi
[Applaudissements]
et
en fait
moi je me rends compte que quand tu
connais un peu les gens c'est vachement
dur d'être raciste
alors moi c'est bon en plus ça a été
très dur je dis les Africains en général
c'était très dur pour moi de pardonner
avec tout ce qui nous ont fait enfin la
décolonisation moi je m'en suis jamais
remis
j'oublie pas que si l'Algérie était
toujours française le prix du gasoil
serait un peu moins élevé
et j'ai
réfléchi quoi je me suis vraiment ouvert
comme une fleur de lotus qui
[Rires]
et en fait tu vois c'est vraiment des
gens comme nous enfin Rachida Dati
Harlem Désir Frédéric Lefebvre ils ont
pas la même couleur mais ils disent les
mêmes conneries tu vois
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui il me reste qui me
reste les
rhums à la télé il y en a pas enfin à
part Sophia à Rome mais
monsieur on peut pas être tout le temps
dans l'amour on ne peut pas tout le
temps être dans l'amour Jésus il est
mort à 33 ans Le Pen il est toujours là
sujet suivant horaires des magasins
alors résumé si j'ai bien compris on va
fermer les magasins dimanche et en
semaine on va réduire les horaires c'est
vraiment une idée géniale c'est
tellement plus agréable de faire les
courses quand tout le monde est là tu
sais
je pense que l'objectif c'est de créer
des files d'attente devant les magasins
et big up l'URSS tu sais
quand tu vois les enjeux des municipales
c'est vraiment la bougeotte des rhums le
stress des mioches la frustration des
bricoleurs du dimanche ça va être quoi
le prochain sujet de polémique le taux
de sucre dans les chouquettes
oui parce que il y a aussi ce truc sur
les rythmes scolaires alors c'est la
zumba des élèves quoi faut alors selon
les médecins il faut que quatre jours et
demi ça c'est le bon rythme c'est bon
c'est des foutaises on va pas assez loin
l'avenir appartient aux gens flexibles
les gamins faut les habituer à nouveau
tes perpétuel c'est pendant une semaine
tu fais 4 jours et demi semaine suivante
5 jours et demi puis 7 tu les réveilles
à 4h du matin surprise
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça
ça c'est du rythme c'est un monsieur
payant ça c'est du rythme puis tu les
déstabilise alors les gars c'est un
prochain classe neige et boum tu les
amène au sel faire du ski tu vois
pas de toute façon l'état il est sadique
il veut faire des rythmes scolaires il
interdit la vente des boissons
énergisantes aux jeunes
Français faut pas trop les exciter déjà
qu'ils ont Jean-Marc Ayrault pour modèle
doucement une chose après l'autre quoi
parce que sinon et puis une fois que
l'école est finie maintenant on promet
une récompense espèce de RSA jeune un
truc pour les 18-25 ans bon pourquoi pas
non moi je me suis renseigné le RSA est
jeune va s'adresser aux jeunes qui n'ont
même pas accès à un emploi d'avenir
l'humiliation tu vas dire au gamin non
mais même un emploi d'avenir c'est pas
pour toi
en fait on va te donner directement une
subvention parce que
c'est ça ou alors une ordonnance pour du
cyanure vraiment on choisit quoi
ça j'ai vu que dès 2017 un jeune sur
trois sera financé par l'État donc par
les contribuables en fait on vient
d'inventer la pension alimentaire pour
les gens qui n'ont pas d'enfants
c'est engagé j'arrête trésorerie
le PS déclare 60 millions de recettes
c'est pas des chiffres définitifs on
attend encore que le fils Fabius rentre
de Deauville
[Musique]
international IALTA sous le patronage de
Poutine et la bienveillance d'Obama
Beyrou a rencontré Bordeaux
en tout cas à Borlo qui se rapproche de
Beyrout c'est Vesoul qui dit à Commercy
vient on va Shanghai
alors terminé par une bonne nouvelle
l'affiche du film Diana a été retirée du
pont de l'Alma ouais non mais ça allait
trop loin en même temps pour une fois
qu'on pouvait rappeler aux Français que
les voitures allemandes ne sont pas
aussi fiables qu'on le dit
alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fête
là je suis tellement content que je
pourrais te faire l'apologie littéraire
de Télé 7 jours
je suis un peu gêné d'habitude je finis
par les bonnes nouvelles mais parce que
des fois c'est
c'est rare
parce que des fois il y a il y a des
événements comme ça tu sais on les
attend ah oui et tu dis ça ça va pas
venir et je sais que tous les Français
partagent cette joie et je suis sûr
qu'ils ont tous pris un jour de congé
quand ils ont appris la nouvelle c'est
confirmé Nicolas est innocent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les grognard il va marcher sur Paris
Foot dehors le bolchevik félon ça va
être quelque chose c'est extraordinaire
non mais c'est un peu d'espoir
parce que tout arrêter de fonctionner
puis le putsch de l'homme qui faisait la
pluie et le cracher ça ça allait plus
moi je le savais qu'il avait rien faire
c'était pas possible un mec de sa classe
ça pudeur Sarko c'est un chat noir il
allait pas escroquer la momie princesse
de la laque en tirée de là c'est pas
possible et quand bien même quand bien
même il y aurait du blé à la bête en
cours hey je veux dire il a quand même
sorti de Colombie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne suis pas partisan non non la
gauche depuis un an et demi elle a fait
des trucs vachement bien aussi elle a
perdu toutes les élections
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est branle-bas de combat les
brainstorming à Morano Lefebvre ont
repris des abonnements bibliothèque
municipales
Balkany est allé acheter du ciment un
baril vide pour couler Fillon dedans
enfin ça va être parce que Fillon en ce
moment il est un peu un peu fais tout à
l'envers c'est parce que la procédure
habituelle en politique c'est quoi tu
dis que tu vas être candidat à la
présidentielle ensuite tu rassemble ta
famille politique et après tu raccores
un peu les voix du FN au second tour
voilà lui non GPS politique détraqué
d'abord il gratte du côté du FN ensuite
il divise sa famille politique et la fin
il dit que les candidats
[Musique]
le mec qui vient d'inventer le Moonwalk
politique
toujours Brignoles cantonale explosive
le PS n'est pas au deuxième tour et le
FN fait plus de 40%. alors la question
que tout le monde se pose mais qui se
cache derrière les électeurs du PS
réponse tout de suite dans enquête
excluante
bonjour je suis Gaspard de la
proustellière
il se dit socialiste il ne s'engage pas
ce soir enquête excluante a voulu en
savoir plus sur ces militants dont les
élus ne dépassent plus le premier tour
de scrutin
Brignoles d'un côté la garrigue les
oliviers des petites gens qui vous
accueillent à coup d'eux alors il y a
trop des trajets
mais Brignoles c'est aussi un visage
plus sombre
l'accent de merde ce sont aussi les
associations de quartier l'engagement
bénévole la défense des citoyens bref le
socialisme
ces gens qui se réclament d'un homme
nommé désir sans sucre un nuage de lait
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr madame un peu de sympathie
ces gens là on les a rencontrés dans un
lieu qu'ils appellent une Asos structure
étonnante car elle ne possède pas de but
lucratif
comme dans tous les groupuscules
radicaux on exalte le sang représenté
par cet affiche d'une main serrant une
rose on leur fait remarquer que c'est
une image qui rappelle les heures
sombres de l'histoire c'est à dire la
vente du muguet le 1er mai
sur deux ils répondent ah bon
tout nos témoins ont eu le courage de
répondre à un visage découvert c'était
Gaspard de la proustellière en
collaboration avec l'agence caca World
chias et flakoslip
bref alors après on peut aussi se poser
quelques questions sérieuses parce que
cette rengaine des électeurs du Front
national mais on l'a déjà tout essayé
sauf le FN c'est dans mon frigo il y
avait plus rien alors j'ai bouffé le bac
à légumes
Assemblée nationale alors un député
imite une poule lors de la prise de
parole d'une collègue franchement c'est
pas plus indécent que lorsque les
députés écoutent héros en imitant un
poulpe mort
alors et puis on a une explication en
fait le député ne se moquait pas de
l'autre député il était juste en train
de traduire pour Christian Jacob
[Applaudissements]
un professeur en garde à vue pour image
pédophile si on commence à stigmatiser
des profs qui s'intéressent vraiment aux
élèves
vacances je me disais en ce moment là
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui trouve tout
ça à Lampedusa
je suis allé sur le site de cette île il
y a pas grand chose à faire
en termes d'hôtellerie il y a qu'un seul
hôtel 4 étoiles et encore le wifi est en
supplément
non c'est vrai alors au fond vous savez
c'est des sujets un peu délicats moi ce
qui me frappe chez les clandestins c'est
pas tant leur socle de connaissance
assez banales en natation
[Musique]
mais leur manque d'exigence oui quand tu
vois ce qu'il y a là-bas le problème
c'est pas d'accueillir toute la misère
du monde mais au moins un peu de son
ambition c'est tout si je peux passer un
message enfin voilà divers une chamelle
a été volée dans un parc animalier de
l'Oise ça sent la voiture bélier halal
sport Paris va accueillir les Gay Games
2018 bon c'était limite il paraît que
tous ces jouets lors du grand oral
un bel événement non non mais la police
c'est pas si on fait
alors c'est un bel événement pour la
télé à part les épreuves de lutte qu'il
faudra passer en crypté
alors bonne nouvelle oui le Nobel de
physique a été décerné à François
hengler et Peter X pour la découverte du
boson de X
très important très très important parce
que tu vois sans ça au quotidien on
pourrait pas expliquer la brisure de
l'interaction unifiée électro faible en
deux interactions par l'intermédiaire du
mécanisme de broute Englert x again
buranique qui bluff donc j'ai envie de
dire faites du buzz au boson
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il est il est parti Moscou vs
c'est con parce que c'était le seul
intime sur le plateau c'est le seul mec
qui connaît le montant de mes impôts
donc
en plus moi je voulais lui dire merci
pour cette très belle réforme fiscale
dans l'égalité juste de la justice
égalitaire pour tous c'est vraiment au
début je pensais qu'il y en avait que
pour nous les riches tu vois toi moi
Tellier Deutsch mais non c'est vraiment
une réforme de cohésion sociale depuis
que les pauvres sont imposées j'ai enfin
trouvé un sujet de discussion avec eux
[Applaudissements]
non mais vraiment grâce à Moscovici un
riche peut enfin se plaindre des impôts
avec impôts c'est maintenant moi je vais
au supermarché tu vois je vois je vois
un retraité comme ça qui se plaint oh là
là c'est la première année que je dois
payer des impôts et moi je fais ouais
c'est vrai c'est dur et puis il me dit
oui en plus je vais pas arriver à payer
l'EDF moi je fais semblant de comprendre
ce que c'est que le DF parce que tu vois
j'ai un comptable qui fait ça je sais
pas au courant ça doit être une niche
fiscale je sais pas votre truc
alors d'ailleurs je me demandais il y a
eu des réformes des des retraites là il
y a la création d'un compte pénibilité
est-ce que ça va concerner les
malheureux qui doivent commenter une
actualité qui n'a aucun intérêt non
parce que pour nous là les mineurs du
PAF c'est dur là c'est pas tous les
jours le 11 septembre moi là je non mais
j'ai un travail très pénible
figurez-vous que pour faire cette
chronique je suis parfois obligé de lire
Marianne ou Libé non
[Musique]
Marianne c'est un peu comme écouter
d'usage quoi tu vas au bout de trois
mesures tu as envie de tondre un peu
caché
bref
[Applaudissements]
jour de France jour en France ça bouge à
Brignoles ça y est ils l'ont fait le
lancement des travaux du futur centre
aquatique intercommunal c'est
que le FN triomphe à Brignoles dans le
Var c'est normal c'est les gens ils
s'attendaient à quoi au Front de Gauche
enfin Brignoles c'est quand même plus
mirador les pins que goulag les Mimosas
les électeurs du FN inexpriment pas leur
ras-le-bol il décompresse
vos TFN dans le Var c'est du Feng Shui
c'est
comme manger 5 fruits et légumes par
jour c'est un réflexe naturel c'est
c'est une vidange quoi de toute façon la
montée du FN je m'en fous totalement ça
me met alors non parce que concrètement
ils vont ils vont changer quoi à
Brignoles qu'est-ce qu'ils vont changer
vous faire un rond-point en forme de ce
mastica
frapper une monnaie locale après le
renfort le brignemou
[Musique]
et puis la préférence nationale ils vont
l'appliquer à qui au type qui viennent
d'Aubagne de Nice enfin tu vois c'est
pas
alors tout le monde dit qu'ils feront un
score très important aux européennes ça
c'est la vraie tragédie du FN l'élection
qui leur réussit le mieux c'est celle où
ils sont obligés d'aller travailler à
l'étranger
[Applaudissements]
il ne faut pas se voiler la face non
parce que l'immigration c'est un
problème en ce moment c'est vrai que
c'est l'invasion il y a trop d'espagnol
Vals à l'intérieur Lopez à Brignoles en
ce moment je serai flic je vérifierai
les papiers de Luis Fernandez
bien pas bien tout ça il est peut-être
pas à sa place c'est vrai qu'on n'a
jamais vu un ministre de l'Intérieur qui
s'occupe autant de l'exportation
et qu'il fait assez mal en termes de
livraison DHL envoyer un rhum au Kosovo
parce qu'il y a ce cas très polémique en
ce moment c'est la fille elle se fait
choper lors d'une sortie scolaire alors
ils allaient visiter une usine Peugeot à
Sochaux moi je comprends qu'on les
retiré avant l'arrivée à destination
[Applaudissements]
quand tu accueilles un étranger chez toi
en vacances tu la mets le voir
Versailles la Tour Eiffel pas aller au
fourneau de Florange tu vois
exécutif le président baisse encore oui
c'est possible
il a beau être contre les gaz de schiste
et la fracturation hydraulique au niveau
popularité il a inventé la fracturation
son d'agir
il existe le trou noir de l'Ifop c'est
le héros baisse aussi mais moi après par
rapport à héros la vraie question c'est
est-ce que les gens qui ont été sondés
savent vraiment qui ont leur a parlé
bon sport alors vous avez vu cette série
de victoires de l'équipe de France ils
ont battu la Biélorussie 4a2 l'Australie
6 à 0 la Finlande 3-0 c'est révélateur
tu comprends qu'ils vont mal quand on
arrive plus à battre des forts on
humilie les faibles
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que les adversaires de la
France ne sont pas terribles en ce
moment mais bon faut pas oublier
qu'avant de pénétrer la Russie
l'Allemagne s'est chauffé en Pologne
quoi non historiquement c'est injuste
après ils ont fait un sondage chez nos
chers compatriotes les joueurs de
l'équipe de France seraient trop payé
individualiste et grossier excusez-les
d'avoir réussi
parce que 82 % des Français ont une
mauvaise opinion des joueurs de foot
c'est inquiétant c'est à dire que 82 %
des Français ont une opinion sur le foot
c'est ça qui est vraiment le
amour un père était condamné une amende
de 500 euros pour avoir remis une fessée
déculottée à son fils 500 euros alors on
dit que le gamin avait les fesses toute
rouge heureusement pour le Père tu vois
s'il l'avait mise moins forte il était
condamné pour pédophilie
puis 500 euros je suis désolé 500 euros
si même la violence conjugale devient un
sport de riche
alors peut-être terminé par une bonne
nouvelle parce que bien sûr évidemment
on ira un père pourra épouser sa fille
adoptive voilà après Paris Barcelone et
Rome on connaît le prochain endroit où
on va tourner Audi Allen
[Applaudissements]
ça fait du bien d'arriver sur c'est
chaud tant d'amour partagé pendant une
heure
moi je vais pas parler les sujets
immigration tout ça non léonarda ah
ouais
non mais la meuf la déstabiliser le pays
ça a eu des répercussions terribles sur
plein de secteurs Nabilla ne dort plus
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
contrairement à Nabilla qui a choisi les
paillettes léonarda a choisi l'école
c'est normal
elle a quand même dû se rendre compte
que pour faire escort c'était pas gagné
une avance
non mais
moi en tout cas j'espère qu'elles vont
pas trop style la bourre parce qu'après
une qui veut faire le buzz l'autre qui
veut faire le contrebasse parce que
Nabilla récemment a fait ça au Grand
Journal et la montre elle a écarté son
entreprise et on a vu son le toboggan à
miosque
léonarda et la même idée je dis on
reçoit déjà assez d'image violente de
Siri tu vois
[Rires]
alors Jean-Vincent Placé a réagi c'est
le seul qui réagi c'est le seul qui a
fait on va faire des manifs de lycéens
pour manifester pour son retour bon
c'est un peu normal je trouve que
leonardin il a tout d'une militante
Europe Écologie le sexe à pile de Duflot
la syntaxe des va-jolie et la moustache
de Noël
je dis ça attention ah je vois je vois
que Lenel me scrute avec ce petit œil
mais
parce que mince mais pardon quoi il y a
pas des sujets plus importants que
stigmatiser les étrangers Philippot
c'est insupportable cette quête du bouc
émissaire bonjour petit mouton de l'Aïd
voir l'autre comme un problème alors
qu'il peut être une solution
aux chutes attention Bambi traverse le
plateau
c'est une honte Ardisson de ce qui se
passe de foulée au pied c'est grands
principes que sont le droit du sol quand
je vois chez moi chaque jour ma femme de
ménage le lustrer avec passion
notre pays c'est un grand pays et on
peut faire des choses comme dirait je ne
sais plus si tu es Sartre ou à nagavalda
mais ensemble c'est tout
non mais nous sommes la République
pardon pardon le creuser republicain ça
existe la grande cocotte nationale qui
agglomère tout c'est pas rien on
pourrait pas se rassembler un peu non
mais tout le monde s'il vous plaît pour
pas un peu touiller agglomérer notre
vivre ensemble dans la fraternité il est
temps que le peuple de France se lit il
faut que les Français féculent
oui l'immigré c'est quoi c'est la
maïzena du lien social
on a tous vocation à être un flageolet
du Grand cassoulet national je vous le
dis moi
un bisounours qui mange une compote avec
un lion
est-ce que ce sont vraiment les
étrangers qui sont responsables d'après
Philippot c'est les étrangers qui sont
responsables de prendre de la France on
veut nous faire croire que la famille de
leonarda abusé de la France que la voie
du travail pardon au contraire elle en a
donné à la CAF au conseil général
à Manuel Valls
à la police désert et des air et on
voudrait se couper de ce relais de
croissance
[Rires]
vu la coccinelle
moi quand moi quand je vois le périple
de cette famille qui affrontait les
dangers pour rejoindre la France de son
Italie natal traverser les Abruzzes la
plaine du pot les orcs du pays du Mordor
les dragons les agents de Saroumane le
gris l'oeil de Schengen qui voit tout
qui surveille tout
et ils ont évité jusqu'à l'arrivée dans
le Doubs pays des hobbits
je sais pas encore si c'est oui c'est ça
c'est une licorne qui accouche
nous le pays de Hugo on se refuserait à
accueillir des petites énerdies
non mais s'il vous plaît
une famille que toute sa place en France
à la télé aussi mais pas la rubrique
faits divers mais dans une famille en or
ou une famille en cuivre je ne sais pas
il faut être sérieux alors on peut se
poser peut-être une seule question la
seule question que personne n'a posé ces
gens qui viennent pour intégrer un pays
plus riche qui veulent offrir à leurs
enfants des meilleurs écoles qui veulent
gagner plus d'argent pour progresser
socialement et montrer aux pays
d'origine qu'ils ont réussi la seule
question que je me pose mais est-ce que
la France a les moyens d'accueillir tous
ces gens de droite
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça mais passons à autre chose
internationale les USA espionnent
toujours et encore la France tu
m'étonnes avec l'affaire léonarda dans
un monde aussi du rétriste c'est quand
même dommage pour les Américains de se
priver de tel barre de rire
bon maintenant qu'ils ont été découvert
les Américains tremblent ah oui quels
vont être les représailles parce que
Hollande il va
interdire la parade de Mickey oui
expulser macronade du territoire proposé
à une fille Obama de venir étudier en
France mais sans ses parents je sais pas
cocasse un Iranien condamné à mort
survit à sa pendaison
alors non c'est vrai à la mort il paraît
qu'il respirait encore c'est inquiétant
ça fait 40 ans que l'Occident se fait
menacer par un pays qui ne sait pas
faire un nœud coulant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Cantat affirme j'ai commis l'irréparable
pourquoi il a fait un duo avec la fouine
[Applaudissements]
détendons un peu l'atmosphère un chinois
a tué sa sœur à coup d'altère bah c'est
le fitness à la chinoise quoi tu fais un
exercice tu perds 55 kg
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle au cinéma sortie de
Gravity donc c'est l'histoire de deux
individus qui l'évite dans leur bulle
au-dessus de la réalité en France on a
la version longue elle dure 5 ans voilà
pas belle la cette semaine on a une
actualité d'une richesse
je pense qu'on tient la semaine la plus
riche depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale
des révoltes à cause d'une taxe sur les
camions et le retour en France des mecs
de Sahel express
avant Hollande je ne savais pas qu'on
pouvait faire autant d'impôts différents
sur tout et n'importe quoi c'est ce que
j'appelle le fist fucking c'est c'est
tout ce qui lui reste pour toucher les
gens quoi c'est un peu mais non non mais
là là la créativité du monsieur quand on
tient le Cyril Lignac de la fiscalité tu
sais demain il quitte le gouvernement il
lance une émission masterfisk un truc
alors depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir il a
lancé 84 mesures fiscales alors on
compare souvent Hollande à Mitterrand on
exagère un peu la grosse différence
entre Mitterrand et Hollande c'est que
Mitterrand lui il a réussi à cacher
qu'il était totalement malade tu vois
[Applaudissements]
quand on pense à ce que l'État a pompé
comme fric est-ce qu'il en fait
si l'État était un joueur de foot ça
serait un branleur de 3e division avec
le salaire de Zlatan
alors
passons d'autre chose nouvelle
frontières les otages ont été libérés et
oui comme disait l'autre le Mali c'est
fini
en une opération on vient prouver que
quatre sorties en français qui arrivent
sur le territoire coûte beaucoup plus
cher que 2 milliers migrés clandestins
Fabius a dit qu'aucun argent public n'a
été versé bon on a eu du bol parce qu'en
fait au moment où le quai d'orsaire su
la facture le fils Fabius rentrait de
Deauville
c'est grand prince
[Applaudissements]
bon
j'ai vu la photo des otages moi je ne
comprends pas très bien enfin pourquoi
il est allé chercher les ravisseurs
je veux pas jeter un froid mais quand on
a libéré les camps les prisonniers sont
pas sortis en uniforme nazi
ils avaient l'air assez tendu moi ça je
comprends c'est trois ans de captivité
tu vois il quitte la France sous Sarko
ils se font accueillir par Hollande
il se dit c'est un coup fourré quoi
c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
berger je me donne alors on leur a filé
20 millions mais comment tu dépenses 20
millions d'euros ça elle
non parce que Tombouctou c'est pas la
capitale internationale du shopping
mais bon les mecs bon ils bouffent des
dates il roulent en pick-up il s'habille
en droit de lit enfin que des trucs que
tu trouves ni chez Hermès ni chez
Vuitton donc tu vois pas le
drame un enfant est tombé de
l'attraction des Pirates des Caraïbes
qu'est-ce qu'on ferait pas pour dégoûter
les immigrants de Lampedusa
rumeurs moyennant les subventions des
villes accueilleraient des populations
noires de Seine-Saint-Denis peu de
choses près ça s'appelle le marché des
transferts en Ligue 1
beauté une fausse chirurgienne a été
arrêtée parce que elle est soupçonnée
d'avoir injecté du ciment dans les
fesses de ses patients
et encore c'est que le début on attend
encore les plaintes de celles qui sont
fait poser du parquet sur le front
[Applaudissements]
le Tour de France va commencer en
Angleterre bon ça c'est normal que tous
les évadés fiscaux l'Angleterre est
devenu un territoire national enfin
c'est alors chaque année le départ du
Tour se fait à l'étranger c'est Belgique
Angleterre Corse la Roumanie on hésite
encore parce que là-bas tu dis caravane
qui va s'élancer vers Paris
c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est piégé femme alors une plainte a
été déposée contre Karl Lagerfeld par
une association de défense des gros
alors l'association s'appelle belle
ronde sexy et je m'assume c'était quand
même plus simple de s'appeler
célibataire et résigné
et peut-être finir par un peu d'amour
parce que c'est
on veut pénaliser la prostitution en
collant une amende de 1500 euros au
client c'est terrible quand on pense
qu'une pipe coûte 20 euros non mais le
sexe tarifait ça va devenir comme les
sens le forage représente 3 % du prix à
la pompe
non mais
ce qu'il faut pénaliser c'est l'amour
l'amour cause beaucoup plus de dégâts
que la prostitution l'amour ça peut vous
faire faire des choses horribles comme
les dîners entre couple une expo sur
l'art primitif ou un concert de Stromae
cimetière alors c'est là tout ça tu sais
que c'est un moment difficile c'est pour
ça que c'est moi je vais sur la tombe
des gens que j'aime je pleure alors pour
remonter le moral faut toujours faire un
tour par les tombes des gens qu'on
n'aime pas comme ça on rééquilibre moi
systématiquement je vais sur la tombe de
Balzac je jette un bouquin de marque
Lévy et je dis alors ringard
et
bien sûr certaines personnes se
demandent comment faire revenir l'être
cher c'est une question alors il y a une
possibilité ça s'appelle la taxidermie
alors j'ai vu une émission je sais qu'il
rencontrait des gens qui ont fait
taxidermiser leur animal de compagnie
c'était vraiment assez c'est bluffant
c'est pas parfait
quand tu jettes un bâton à ton chien
taxidermisé aussi jeter le chien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle de la soirée peut-être un
nouveau pas été franchi dans la lutte
contre la gastro ah oui il est mort
l'inventeur du kebab
alors c'est un moment assez important
nous sommes le 9 novembre c'est une date
vraiment très importante enfin pour
l'Allemagne parce que c'est un 9
novembre qui a été proclamé la
République de Weimar qui a échoué le
putsch de Munich et la chute du mur de
Berlin c'est vrai en France le seul truc
qui soit arrivé à 9 novembre c'est la
naissance de David Guetta et Jennifer
[Applaudissements]
c'est à ce genre de détail que tu dis
que ça sert à rien de se tirer la bourre
avec l'Allemagne
on peut pas être compétitif on peut pas
être compétitif même en histoire bon le
9 novembre c'est aussi la mort du
général de Gaulle en France comme quoi
entre perdu un de perdus
en ce moment le temps est à l'orage
c'est un peu les masses Celtes grondes
aux portes du Royaume c'est un peu
angoissant alors à tous les niveaux les
gens perdent leurs repères par exemple
l'histoire de cette dame qui a
démissionné du FN parce qu'elle s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait des racistes
parmi les militants
mais enfin faut bien adhérer au FN pour
des raisons valables
non mais quand même enfin il y a plus de
soleil il y a plus de soleil même NKM a
sorti son programme pour Paris un
programme qui fait rêver tu as la mesure
phare prolongée d'une heure l'ouverture
des métros la nuit
quand même dans le métro on aura droit à
une heure de plus pour se faire
racketter merci Nathalie
alors
c'est pas
c'est pas la seule idée elle va aussi
abolir la frontière du périphérique elle
est au courant que la Seine-Saint-Denis
Montreuil Saint-Ouen ça fait partie de
l'espace Schengen
non mais c'est vraiment dramatique tout
le monde est déboussolé mais moi je suis
je suis extrêmement mal j'ai j'ai perdu
ma muse
leonarda est parti
moi cette meuf elle a changé ma vie il y
a deux semaines on tenait quand même la
famille défouloirs idéales il y avait
rien à faire fallait juste tu vois et
depuis qu'elle est partie bam retour du
racisme ordinaire c'est mathématique ce
que se prennent en ce moment les noirs
et les Arabes c'est tout ce que prennent
plus les robes
c'est les vases communicants alors il y
a bien eu les manifs des lycéens mais
bon c'est un fiasco bon c'est normal sur
le parcours il y avait trop de McDo et
de Starbucks alors
puis il pleuvait il pleuvait c'est un
facteur c'est dormait 68 il y a moi de
mai
ça n'existe pas un mouvement lycéen du
mois de février novembre les manifs
c'est comme les moules il y a des mois
pour en manger
[Applaudissements]
et de temps en temps on s'envoie des
messages Facebook avec leonarda et là le
blues dans elle m'a envoyé une photo
d'un portique écotax avec la phrase mais
qu'est-ce qu'elle a de plus que moi
pendant ce temps la droite espère on
leur fait le coup de l'ex qui va revenir
Sarkozy tout ça alors il y a eu un
documentaire extraordinaire sur D8 enfin
c'est pas un documentaire on dirait
plutôt une vidéo pédagogique intitulée
le cadrage tout ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire
bon les images sont assez terribles
Sarko au téléphone pendant que Carla
joue de la guitare faites le mec il a
pas épousé un mannequin mais un concert
privé
on aurait dit André Manoukian qui se
fait harceler par une candidate recalée
à la Nouvelle Star
mariage pour tous dans cette période un
peu terne marquée par le racisme et la
colère il y a Berrou Borlo qui se sont
dit oui
beau message envoyé à la diversité tu
sais le Bernay bec qui se tape le Ch'ti
hédoniste
non mais sérieusement qu'est-ce qu'on
s'en fout franchement alors leur mariage
ça m'a fait l'effet de clochards
toxicoman qui se foutent au doigt une
capsule de canette en se disant je
t'aime mais elle est où la dose tu sais
mode Martine Aubry se bat comme une
lionne pour que la Redoute ne ferme pas
bon c'est normal c'est affectif on se
bat toujours pour son couturier préféré
[Applaudissements]
prostitution alors ils vont vraiment
pénaliser ça va vraiment se faire ça va
faire tourner la tête de toutes les
prostituées et de voir leurs clients
prendre une amende de 1500 euros ça va
avec cette mesure tout ce qu'on va voir
c'est que les prostituées du périph vont
se prendre pour des escorts du 8e
automobile le PDG de Peugeot a été
cambriolé et s'est fait piquer 70 mille
euros 70 euros alors bon il était un peu
dégoûté parce que malgré leur présence
sur la commode personne n'a piqué les
clés de sa 450
[Applaudissements]
foot
grève voilà à cause de la taxe 75% bon
j'ai regardé un peu la physionomie
financière de la Ligue 1 alors adjaccio
et Bastia il y a une seule personne qui
gagne au minimum un million d'euros par
an c'est l'arbitre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
technologie une application pour
smartphone pour dénoncer les actes
islamophobes ça existe alors pour
dénoncer les actes Cristiano FOB c'est
plus compliqué parce qu'en général quand
ça t'arrive tu as plus de portable
[Applaudissements]
restauration chez Coste on place les
moches au fond pour les cacher et les
beaux devant pour montrer que le lieu
s'adresse à des gens raffinés au Flunch
c'est l'inverse
[Applaudissements]
gastronomie toujours un couple meurt
après avoir mangé des champignons
vénéneux on insistera jamais assez sur
la nécessité d'une bonne hygiène intime
nous les hommes
bonne nouvelle alors on a retrouvé un
corps dans la Seine et un crâne dans la
baie d'Antibes ça c'est impressionnant
le réseau hydraulique français
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut rester un peu dim parce que
cette semaine c'était les commémorations
du 11 novembre donc il faut passer une
date très importante dans l'histoire
franco-allemande très quand même le seul
moment de l'histoire ou la France et
l'Allemagne ont réussi à synchroniser
les congés payés
d'ailleurs Hollande était assez mal à
l'aise devant la tombe du soldat inconnu
bon c'est normal quoi un moment il a
entendu toquer ouvre-moi ces gens Marc
tu vois donc
sinon rien de rien de nouveau en ce
moment la France elle a pas la pêche
enfin le bras elle est pas après le
mariage pour tout ce qui nous a tenu en
haleine pendant un an voici venu le
temps du fruit exotique pour personne
[Musique]
comme chaque semaine la République est
en danger ouais c'est vraiment une
petite la République
il suffit d'un jeu de mots douteux
griffonné par un journal qui a autant
d'impact que la revue motocross chez les
cul-de-jatte pour qu'elle nous fasse une
gastro-entérite verbale femme bon comme
beaucoup de monde j'ai été choqué enfin
c'est quand même elle a une deux minutes
des skinnettes qui savent manier
l'ironie je suis pas
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai fait comme tout
le monde
j'ai voulu acheter minute bon j'y suis
allé molo pour pas éveiller les soupçons
du buraliste tu es bonjour vous avez le
magazine zoophilie et travaux
non non et la revue valeur pédophile
parce que non parce que c'est pas pour
moi c'est dans le cadre d'un exposé sur
fuchisme au moment bien sûr allons aux
enfants de là un dîner nous étions tous
indignés
alors le mec
alors le mec qui m'a douché elle m'a dit
ah bah non moi minutes j'aime bien ça
m'apprend plein de choses est-ce qu'il
était de Brignoles donc mais il m'a dit
attention je suis de Brignoles au nord
de derrière la rocade parce que les gens
de brio le sud bon ils sont pas comme
nous alors là j'ai fait marche arrière
tout de suite Marion Maréchal nous voilà
et
là il me dit et là il me dit elle
est bonne la petite alors je dis ah
ouais c'est vrai mais
et là il me dit ben désolé de vous
décevoir mais minutes j'en ai plus
d'habitude j'en vends deux par mois et
là depuis le début de la journée ça fait
la 15e fois qu'on le demande moi je me
suis dit les socialistes sont quand même
fort de publicité
bon sinon cette semaine encore et
toujours on parle de
Hollande Hollande il déçoit il se fait
siffler il doit remanier ça va quoi
c'est le mec c'est pas non plus le
président de la République
bravo bravo
Gaspard
énorme ce qui est quand même intéressant
avec les sondages sur Hollande c'est
qu'on va bientôt pouvoir connaître
l'identité des gens qui le soutiennent
[Applaudissements]
de personnes très satisfaites donc sur
1000 personnes ça fait 20 personnes qui
peuvent appeler le numéro vert suivant
bon après les Français sont un peu con
je pense qu'on l'a assez ils sont déçus
ils sont en colère au lieu de se mettre
un bonnet rouge mettez-vous un bonnet
d'âne pour croire encore un homme
providaniel
[Applaudissements]
qui peut encore rentrer dans le costume
de De Gaulle je rappelle qu'il faisait 2
mètres enfin sur le général la vie de
Président c'est un costard mais sur
Sarko Hollande ça fait burqa
[Applaudissements]
je pense parce qu'il a besoin d'amour
cet homme là
il a pas encore trouvé sa voie il
cherche je pense que Hollande c'est le
plus vieil emploi jeune de France
non mais quand on pense qu'il est plus
impopulaire que Sarko alors que dans son
entourage il y a même pas Nadine Morano
non parce que Sarko avait une entourage
beaucoup plus pittoral quoi
voilà présentatrice télé un bouquin sur
verdict les nanas de Hollande elles vont
faire quoi après faire Marisol Touraine
elle va rebondir dans quoi le tirage des
tarots et Jerry Afflelou tu vois
alors
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on y a ailleurs
j'aimerais vraiment
qui mais qui dégommer il y a Copé
on peut pas enfin on est humain il a les
mêmes sondages que Hollande sans être au
pouvoir il a besoin de personne
[Applaudissements]
international Philippines alors tout le
monde a entendu ce drame tu me connais
j'ai fait un geste pour les Philippines
j'ai une salle de ménage qui vient de
là-bas alors je lui ai dit oui
aujourd'hui vous touchez pas la
baignoire la douche le séchoir
[Applaudissements]
après tu
me connais j'ai pas pu m'empêcher pour
lui faire peur j'ai fait un courant
d'air
enfin j'ai appelé les pompiers pour la
descente du lustre
musique Pleyel le fabricant de piano a
fermé son usine en Seine-Saint-Denis pas
grand corps malade a vu ça il a dit bah
c'est normal aujourd'hui plus personne
tape à la machine
sexe pour revenir à Hollande Nabilla
conseil à Hollande de faire une sextape
pour annoncer sa popularité avec des
déclarations pareil on a hâte que
Nabilla soit un populaire
ah oui peut-être terminé sur une bonne
nouvelle oui parce que Aubry est
pressenti à Matignon ça serait malin si
elle se plante et pourra toujours dire
oui mais moi je bosse 35 heures
ça a remonté le moral votre débat à la
fin c'est au cours vers le précipice
[Rires]
bon après les polémiques de la semaine
passée la République est passée à autre
chose oui parce que c'est aussi ça la
France la République c'est vraiment une
pouf
quand est-ce là ça se casse tu vois ce
truc alors tu veux qu'on divertisse et
bien on va t'en donner une
divertissement conasse
tiens par exemple un faux majeur arrivé
du Beaujolais nouveau avec cette
question cette année est-ce qu'il aura
le goût de banane
[Rires]
hélas non et là sinon comme d'habitude
il a ce goût de kiwi ma série dans du
vinaigre
et ouais il y a pas bon je l'ai
pardon
mais cette semaine c'est une semaine
contrairement à ce qui a été disputé
chargé donc positive la magie du
football moi j'adore le football c'est
c'est tellement intelligent c'est
tellement subtil mais mais comment au
21ème siècle peut-on encore préférer
lire un livre quand on a la chance de
m'atterriberry coursant un ballon comme
un clébard hystérique aboyant sur le
postier du village c'est d'une beauté
et on a réussi on a battu les Ukrainiens
on est bon on est on est comme ça quoi
nous on arrive à se bouger le cul que
lorsqu'on se fait humilier en fait
autant en tirer quelques leçons le
successeur de Deschamps faudra pas le
chercher dans un club de foot mais dans
un club SM
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec
je vois déjà la petite annonce équipe de
baltringue sur friqué blasé cherche
maîtresse dominatrice pour humiliation
planétaire
mais avant cette victoire quelle tapage
alors j'ai regardé la conférence de
presse avant le match c'était Giroud qui
était prêt à mourir sur la pelouse
encore raté
non les mecs qu'il faut arrêter de leur
faire faire des conférences de presse
ils sont pas équipés pour ça quoi
non faut trouver d'autres moyens pour
qu'il communique leurs émotions je sais
pas le dessin la poterie tu vois un truc
non mais quand t'entends Giroud en
conférence de presse bon bah tu es
content qu'il fasse pas pilote de ligne
quoi
c'est le mec qui fait commandant de bord
il est capable de cracher l'avion sans
décoller c'est un moment
alors la question la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'a dit Deschamps pour
motiver les joueurs moi je sais
j'ai le réseau connais la réponse c'est
ce qu'il a dit vous savez les gars au
Brésil y en a plein des mecs comme Zahia
Gaspard
[Applaudissements]
sinon autre chose quelque chose de
majeur oui alors on vient de sauver le
quinquennat contrairement à tout ce que
on vient de sauver le quinquennat on a
compris que pour faire plaisir aux
Français il suffit de simplifier les
impôts
mais enfin c'est bien sûr monsieur les
Français ils souffrent pas de pays trop
d'impôts au contraire ils en raffolent
c'est juste qu'ils veulent comprendre à
quelle sauce ils se font manger c'est
tout
comme disait mon banquier le problème
c'est pas de se faire enfiler c'est
juste d'avoir une visibilité sur le
diamètre
[Applaudissements]
parce que là et c'est là où est héros
qui en prend plein la tronche mais il
est il écoute les gens il écoute il
touche une vraie problématique il est au
diapason de la société parce que parce
que ici c'est la préoccupation majeure
des gens enfin il faut être con
t'imagines la famille française typique
le type qui rentre le soir qui rentre de
l'usine il se retrouve à table et que sa
femme avec ses gosses le chômage qui lui
pend au nez il dit à la petite famille
bon écoute Nadine apparemment ils vont
délocaliser le boulot je suis plus sûr
la propriétaire madame roux elle parle
d'augmenter le loyer mais c'est pas le
plus grave il y a plus inquiétant mais
quoi chérie tu as le cancer tu as flashé
sur la bouchère non
c'est pire
c'est pas pour tout de suite la fusion
de la CSG de l'impôt sur le revenu
[Applaudissements]
pour le reste c'est que cette semaine je
dois dire Hollande a été impeccable elle
a trouvé un conflit à sa taille le
Proche-Orient c'est normal pas de
solution simple pour en Orient compliqué
disait de Gaulle c'était une mission
pour Hollande
bonjour Je complique donc ça doit être
simple tu vois du aisance le type c'est
le mec qui chaleure entre les mines et
salamalek entre les barbelés là c'est
c'était lui ou Julien Courbet quoi
problème de voisinage c'est les
meilleurs
non mais quand tu arrives à faire une
coloc avec Vals tobira Montebourg et
désire le Proche-Orient sur une
maternelle
je savais pas mais il est polyglotte il
parle hébreu et arabe et le mec c'est
Captain Shalom aleykoum
c'est là où on fait on voit ses limites
plutôt que d'être président il aurait
fait un excellent maire de Deauville ou
de Marseille
peur sur la ville passons à autre chose
alors on a attrapé le méchant ouf moi
j'en pouvais plus quoi ça tronche au JT
les chaînes info là c'est pas contre lui
mais bon
enfin on tient le premier criminel qui
est à l'image de la présidente actuelle
quoi le mec qui n'a aucun cap
[Applaudissements]
le type il hésite chez BFM et canard
d'un stagiaire chez Libé il prend un
otage un mec sur les champs qui relâche
au bout de trois secondes devant
distributeur de la Société générale il
tire trois coups de feu et on le
retrouve dans un parking sous l'ombre
Mesrine il voit ça il se dit c'est qui
se blaireau quoi
[Applaudissements]
alors on a eu une info alors il
s'appelle Abdelhakim deskar
on comprend mieux pourquoi il a attaqué
l'idée il aurait attaqué minute c'est
lui qui se prenait un coup de fusil à
pompe
[Applaudissements]
mais des choses vont mieux par exemple
en Bretagne en Bretagne on entend moins
les Bretons la contestation c'est
souffle mais ça c'est normal ils ont
détruit tous les portiques
c'est bon quoi c'est pareil qu'il reste
un portique et de radar qui marche en
Bretagne c'est bon c'est cool maintenant
si tu as une conduite un peu sportive
grâce au bonnet rouge Paris c'est à deux
heures de Quimper
[Applaudissements]
parlons monnaie on a emprunté 4,5
milliards pour solder l'ardoise du
Crédit Lyonnais alors pas d'inquiétude
Thomas Fabius se porte caution
[Rires]
international c'est deux lionsceaux sont
nés dans le zoo de Gaza ouais alors bon
il y a un truc qui porte les noms des
deux roquettes tirées vers Israël
non mais attention c'est des roquettes
super importantes c'est les seuls qui
ont passé le mur donc est-ce que les
mecs c'est pas des artilleurs quoi c'est
pas avec eux en face Verdun ça aurait
durer une après-midi quoi tu vois
moi je les trouve d'ailleurs assez dur
les Palestiniens avec la colonisation
israélienne une colonise c'est il faut
être un peu honnête en général quand tu
colonies c'est pour accaparer des
ressources
non mais coloniser la Palestine je veux
dire à moins d'être fasciné par les
Mercedes des années 60 le sable et
l'huile d'olive
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas
happy birthday on commémore le
cinquantenaire de la mort de Kennedy bon
ok mais faut arrêter quel frimeur quand
même rouler en décapotable à 22 novembre
faut pas s'étonner qu'après tu attrapes
un coup de froid carabiné quoi c'est
[Applaudissements]
mais quelle est la vraie bonne nouvelle
et bah dans le cadre d'un plan pour la
lutte contre l'obésité à Moscou on peut
avoir un ticket de métro gratuit contre
30 flexion ouais j'ose pas imaginer ce
qu'il faut faire pour le bus gratuit à
Mykonos alors
dimanche
j'ai chopé la grippe donc je peux dire
que toute ma vie j'ai jamais autant fait
la bise aux gens
d'habitude j'ai un herpès en même temps
et ça m'a ça m'a bloqué bon on est
généreux on n'est pas enfin bon quoi de
neuf plein de trucs extraordinaires
cette semaine l'éducation nationale
alors selon le classement de la pizza en
termes de scolarité on est nul on est
vraiment bon si la France recule c'est
par humilité on veut pas humilier par
notre niveau scolaire les pays dont on
va finir par rejoindre le niveau de vie
on est
le problème en fait c'est le niveau des
profs on a trouvé un prof qui a une
moyenne de 4 sur 20 à ces examens de
profs
pour peu que le mec a eu 18 en travaux
manuels et 16 ans flûte à bec
tu as une petite idée de c'est note en
maths quoi tu dis enfin le principe de
l'école c'est que c'est le prof qui
apprend au gosse pas l'inverse
avec une moyenne pareil tu m'étonnes que
les profs refont plusieurs fois la même
année c'est pas par choix c'est juste
pour finir par comprendre ce qu'ils
enseignent
[Applaudissements]
alors la bonne nouvelle ça fait pareil
qu'on est un système très performant
pour les élites alors c'est un système
qui est adapté aux gens très voilà c'est
vrai que quand on voit les élites
françaises qu'est-ce qu'elle lui mette à
la mondialisation tu vois si Mercedes
appelle Google n'investisse pas en
France c'est juste par complexe
d'infériorité
théâtre subventionné après Olivier pipe
a trichéro la France découvre le génie
scénique de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
impressionnant de maturité tu lui donnes
un trottoir cas de figurant il te fait
Ben-Hur
vie nocturne après David Cathy Guetta et
Régine le PS s'est mis organisé des
soirées à thème génial c'est le concept
c'est la soirée lieu commun tu vois tu
trouves une évidence tout le monde doit
être pour et boum DJ et là c'était la
soirée contre la haine alors il prévoit
aussi une soirée 1 + 1 = 2 la night de
la pluie qui mouille ça va être
alors c'est vraiment les seules soirées
où j'arrive à me trouver génial parce
que tu déblatères une banalité les gens
disent oh alors j'ai abordé une
fille je lui ai dit franchement la une
deux minutes c'est nauséabond elle m'a
dit Marine Le Pen se trouve pas que
c'est une facho
c'est des trucs je commence tu dis et là
tu sais enfin je te regarde
dans les yeux et je viens de me faire
traverser par un sentiment étrange mais
je trouve pas que la paix ça fait moins
de morts que la guerre
et attends attends tu m'inspires un truc
au fond j'ai l'impression que tous les
hommes naissent libres et Go en droit
alors la fille scotchée m'a dit toi tu
as dû faire normal sup' quoi
écoute on s'en fout des études ce qui
compte c'est le cœur là elle m'a dit on
va chez toi ou chez moi je dis non c'est
gentil mais je me remettrai à faire
l'amour que lorsqu'on aura éradiqué la
fin dans le monde en revanche une pipe
aux toilettes
[Applaudissements]
foot cette polémique le PSG a commencé
son match contre Lyon sans un seul
joueur français
excusez-les d'avoir envie de gagner
sondage alors on sent que c'est on sent
que c'est l'hiver on part déjà de la
bouffe qui colle à l'estomac ceci fait
froid les frimas le rein de Chirac la
prostate de Hollande oh mais moi je suis
inquiet Hollande où il en est essayé de
faire du buzz avec un abat il aurait pu
trouver un morceau noble quoi tu vois
j'ai mal aux abdos
c'est une opération de prostate qui a
soulevé beaucoup de questions c'est un
phénomène il paraît que c'est la
première prostate qui arrive à
fonctionner sans testicule
[Applaudissements]
alors
on l'a retrouvé dans une crèche dans une
position bon après le président des
bisous le président des nounou c'est
cette photo vraiment elle a fait mal
mais elle s'adresse aux Français elle a
dit vous voyez moi aussi j'ai les mains
dans la merde
mais je comprends pourquoi il a un peu
du coup c'est pas le surpoids c'est les
oreillons parce qu'à force faire des
crèches
[Applaudissements]
international Afghanistan après 12 ans
de guerre ça progresse
ils vont rétablir la lapidation pour
adultère
c'est normal c'est normal dans un pays
où il y a rien c'est quand même super
indécent d'avoir une vie sexuelle
pimentée
alors dans la foulée ils ont aussi sorti
un rapport qui estime que les cultures
de substitution à l'opium ont échoué
non mais sans la c'est vrai que c'est
super courant le dealer qui vient de
voir en boîte et qui dit écoute j'ai pas
de coq en revanche des salsifis et des
rats du Touquet
elles viennent d'un producteur
et demain je reçois des pêches du
Roussillon ça va vraiment faire des
dégâts
[Rires]
Ukraine les manifestants veulent que
l'Ukraine intègre l'Europe ça leur
suffit pas de perdre à l'UEFA à lui
revision ils veulent en plus se faire
humilier à la BCE
alors évidemment l'Ukraine fait du bruit
et les Femen réagissent elles sont
urinés sur la photo du président
ukrainien c'est bizarre les happniques
des Femen c'est quelque chose ça devient
un mix entre la FIAC Michaël Youn et une
visite médicale
[Applaudissements]
sexe
en matière de passer sexuel les hommes
déplorent les occasions manquées et les
femmes les expériences décevantes c'est
tellement vrai je me souviendrai
toujours de ce moment où est la claqué
la porte quand j'ai fait rentrer l'âne
dans la chambre
[Applaudissements]
j'ai compris ah le chanteur M a fait une
prestation dans le métro à Paris alors
je veux pas juger mais je trouve que
c'est pas la manière la plus futée de se
faire du fric au black
bon le côté positif ça va peut-être
donner des idées aux ce serait
une bonne idée les dans le
métro surtout sur les rails
non mais pas vous pas vous pas vous
enfin non vous êtes un peu à part dans
les vous êtes le seul qui
arrivait à vivre de votre métier
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle alors ouais ce soir il y
a deux grosses soirées Miss France ou
Téléthon
c'est pas par machisme je préfère Miss
France c'est quand même plus facile de
s'attacher à des personnes dont on est à
peu près sûr qu'elle passeront l'hiver
et qui pour les plus talentueux se
finiront peut-être dans un porno
alors pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
bon bah
joyeux Noël
enfin c'est chouette comme fait quoi on
se rassemblent en famille on boit des
coups et on regarde Maman j'ai raté
l'avion 5 sur TF1 c'est
petit conseil aux enfants qui sont en
train de courir autour du sapin comme
c'est l'année du Qatar remplacer les
souliers par des babouches ça va plus
bon sinon qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
enfin le monde avance Mandela est enfin
enterré ça maladie va enfin pouvoir
souffler un peu
ouais parce que six mois d'aller venu à
la fin à la grippe aussi elle est malade
quoi
politique nationale la Centrafrique ça
avance aux dernières nouvelles Hollande
aurait retrouvé l'avion pour rentrer
donc c'est c'est chic en ce moment il
voyage beaucoup pauvre petite chatte
à courroux sur le site de lancement des
fusées Ariane il s'est senti comme un
poisson dans l'eau c'est normal c'est
une fusée c'est quoi c'est c'est un
dispositif qui explose une fois sur deux
pour terminer en orbite dans le vide
intersidéral à peu de choses près le
destin d'une loi du gouvernement héros
[Applaudissements]
le 29 et 30 décembre il a prévu de se
rendre en Arabie Saoudite il aime le
challenge ça c'est est-ce qu'il va
arriver à faire pleuvoir là-bas
à propos de nuages en ce moment il y en
a eu des très sombres cette polémique
sur ce fameux rapport sur l'intégration
ça fait beaucoup de beaucoup de vagues
c'est un merveilleux rapport on va enfin
réécrire l'histoire c'est chouette
Charles Martel se dangereux rétrograde
nazi qui s'est battu à l'arbe blanche
contre les nobles défenseurs de la
cantine halal dans les régions au-dessus
de la Loire ça va être alors il y a une
chose le rapport est très bien écrit
j'ai compilé la langue du rapport qui
est d'une beauté je cite faire France
dans un ou inclusif et solidaire qui
permettrait de faire de l'encomment à
travers une nouvelle forme
d'universalité au bénéfice de tous c'est
écrit un truc pareil au bac philo non
seulement terre Calais mais en plus on
annule ton brevet des collèges tu vois
quand Hollande a su pour le rapport il a
dit ouais il faut pas effrayer les
Français avant les élections c'est vrai
il devrait en profiter parce que eux ils
risquent de l'effrayer pendant
mais ça ça veut dire un truc ça veut
dire qu'en fait c'est même pas une
tactique pour faire monter le Front
national non le mec il est sincère
je pensais qu'on avait un mec qui jouait
au con pour enfumer tout le monde mais
en fait non non c'est c'est Mr Bean
c'est lui c'est bien lui
[Applaudissements]
alors certains disent certains disent
qu'ils devraient remanier pourquoi faire
il y a les meilleurs
c'est vrai monarchie qui n'a aucun
rapport alors il est né le divin enfant
fruit de gad El Charlotte on n'a pas
encore sa photo mais on peut d'ores et
déjà dire qu'il a l'argent de son père
et l'argent de sa mère
[Applaudissements]
international les athées humanistes et
libres penseurs risquent la peine de
mort dans 13 pays alors j'ai regardé la
liste des pays c'est bizarre Mauritanie
Soudan Somalie Iran
Arabie Saoudite
Qatar Pakistan Afghanistan et je me dis
mais
c'est quoi le truc en commun
je suis sûr je suis je suis sûr qu'il y
a un truc mais je vois pas je vais
peut-être plus tard dans le je sais pas
je trouve pas tu vas le trouver je vais
trouver peut-être inch'Allah
cinéma il est mort le plus grand acteur
qui est porté la Corrèze Peter o tulle
humanisme des employés ont perdu leur
emploi via SMS alors comme quoi on fait
des progrès c'est vachement plus humain
ça rappelle les ruptures amoureuses
divertissement alors on la démantelé un
réseau de plus de chinoise dans les
caves des tours du 13e arrondissement
des nems à la chez les Chinois tout
semble rouler dans un endroit sombre et
humide
[Applaudissements]
amour
Nabilla Zahia et Ribéry sont les
personnalités les moins aimées des
Français on n'a pas le droit de
stigmatiser toute une famille comme ça
c'est moche
statistique il paraît que 27% des
délinquants sont étrangers ouf
Montebourg peut être content ça veut
dire que globalement la délinquance
reste un truc made in France
crime un braquage a été commis avec les
masques de François Hollande oui c'est
vrai que des en déguisés en c'est sûr
que si on peut neutraliser les victimes
avec un regard c'est
en cas de non efficacité les braqueurs
imitent la voix Duflot aussi c'est
la généralement ça marche
sexualité vintage un homme blessé par un
obus de 39-45 alors on ne le dit jamais
assez en matière de sextoy toujours
utilisé du matière Ariel neuf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors il y a une bonne nouvelle mais que
j'ai que j'ose pas faire parce que je
pense que c'est vraiment ça pourrait
tellement mieux convenir à Stéphane donc
je vais si tu veux bien sûr je veux pas
je t'en prie vas-y oui oui
bonne nouvelle Nadine Morano tête de
liste au européennes dans le Grand Est
je ne sais pas vous mais moi Stéphane
Guillon j'ai hâte de voter pour elle
enfin sauf si le FN propose une
alternative plus à droite
[Applaudissements]
alors pas belle la vie
copine de La Celle Sylvestre couillons
du réveillon bonsoir
bienvenue dans cette chronique
transitoire entre deux agapes qui sans
doute vous mettre le foie dans un tel
état que si on commercialisé du foie
gras d'homme et bien ce serait la bonne
période pour vous abattre
chance nous habitons dans un pays aux
normes sanitaire très strict ou les
religions s'accordent à dire que l'homme
est trop sale pour être halal
très accent pourri qui n'apporte rien
d'autre que juste vous dire que je parle
aussi des langues tribales
ah qu'il fait bon d'être né au dessus de
la Loire
cette année donc ces restrictions à tous
les étages avec des proches on est allés
au Resto du Coeur bon après du casse ce
qu'on voulait atterrir tranquillement
quand même là on a fait une action de
sensibilisation beaucoup des gens un peu
des gens un peu plus moins équipés
financièrement
alors on a fait un test alors dans la
soupe moulinée qui servent on a fait
deux groupes à un groupe on a servi de
la vraie truffe et un autre à placer
beau c'est à dire des petits bouts de
pneus crevés
et ben crois-le ou pas les clients
réclamaient le placer
[Applaudissements]
parce que disait
ça leur appelait vachement plus le
terroir
bref pour ce trou normand entre de
remonter acide j'aimerais vous rappeler
que vous avez peut-être déjà oublié des
choses qui sont passées en 2013 une
année précaire normale 64 millions de
personnes sur un pédalo m'autorisé par
les mollets de René Coty bon ben c'est
plus de la navigation c'est
l'exploration des abysses une année
coulée bon ce sont des événements et des
hommes il y a des hommes qui font des
événements il y a des événements qui
font les hommes puis à François Hollande
qui fait ah bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est
c'est évidemment l'homme incontournable
cette année on ne peut pas il y a pas de
godie possible souvenez-vous déjà ça
commençait généralement chef au Mali il
pète une durite il envahit le Mali et il
a appelé l'opération militaire
l'opération Serval alors le serval je
rappelle c'est un petit félin qui a la
particularité de pisser 30 fois en une
heure pour marquer son territoire
comme quoi être intronisé sous la pluie
ça marque un ça donne un style quoi
alors bon la guerre on l'a gagné
c'était un peu prévisible elle va pas se
faire démonter par des mecs qui savent
pas faire une carte UNICEF
autre sujet le mariage pour tous quelle
polémique quelle polémique je me
souviens de cette blague qui est un
député qui faisait les marchés le
dimanche qui disait mais vous savez le
chômage nous on lutte et les gens qui
disaient
occupe-toi plutôt du mariage gay
d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
et
moi en tout cas à l'époque j'étais
extrêmement choqué par certains slogans
vraiment nauséabond lui il y en avait un
terme c'était zéro maman c'est déprimant
on voit qu'ils connaissent pas ma mère
je veux dire ma mère en termes
d'optimisme Houellebecq c'est un géo du
Club Med
paria de l'année 2013 Jérôme Cahuzac
Cahuzac qui était décrit comme l'un des
meilleurs du gouvernement mais il
mentait il mentait que
a laissé une lettre dans laquelle il
s'est dit dévasté par le remords dévasté
bah c'est sûr s'il avait placé un peu
plus de fréquence Suisse sur le
peut-être pas eu besoin de revenir en
France qui ont été
fashion victime de l'année Clément Méric
militant d'extrême gauche
anticapitaliste qui met au cours d'une
vente privée pourquoi pas négationniste
qui décide dans une chambre à gaz
femme de l'année Taubira quand même on
se rattrape taubirac a déclaré que la
prison forme la délinquance c'est vrai
en gros pour paraphraser Rousseau tous
les délinquants naissent bon c'est la
prison qui les rend mauvais
non mais
c'est vrai que la prison c'est peut-être
pas la solution idéale pour un
délinquant en revanche pour le voisinage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le groupe de l'année n'en déplaise à
Laurent Voulzy les to be free est en
dissout les Spice Girls à la retraite
cette année c'est le groupe les Roms qui
ont fait le buzz
dans la section au cuivre ils sont
imbattables
[Applaudissements]
on en a beaucoup parlé les Roms les
robes les robes et c'est vrai que toutes
ces polémiques un moment on se pose une
question pourquoi est-ce qu'on les
stigmatistes tellement parce que ça fait
du bien
prostitution autre sujet majeurs alors
il y a une loi qui a été votée donc
maintenant les clients seront désormais
pénalisés de 1500 euros ou du double
s'il récidive et ben oui quand on pense
qu'une pipe coûte 20 euros là il sera à
1520 euros c'est-à-dire la fille elle va
se donner tu vois
pin-up de l'année
Kennedy avait Marilyn Hollande à
léonarda
[Applaudissements]
le routard de l'année les otages qui
sont rentrés et qui ils ont eu de la
chance dans leur malheur vu le niveau
des impôts pour eux fiscalement c'était
une année blanche
ah oui
destination touristique de l'année
Lampedusa petite
île des côtes italienne cette Corse qui
ne dépassons non pas une île tellement
attractive que les touristes sont prêts
à venir à la nage
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle alors faut quand même
donner de l'espoir l'année est finie la
mauvaise c'est que vu ce que nous attend
vous risquez de la regretter l'année
2013 alors ma belle la vie et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu